JOSH HUDGINS: Good morning.
So I'm Josh Hudgins.
I'm a Product Manager
on Drive.
This is my esteemed colleague,
Steve Bazyl, a Developer
Advocate for Drive.
We're going to spend a few
minutes this morning talking
about your apps and getting them
noticed inside of Google
Drive and the value Drive
can deliver to
your app as a platform.
So I'm going start
with this quote.
"The best computer you have is
the one you have when you want
to get something done." And
this speaks to how we're
increasingly living in
a multi-device world.
I think that's a reality that
pretty much everybody here
would be familiar with.
But the part of that I really
want to focus on is when you
reach for whatever device is
near you to do something,
users are increasingly expecting
to only be able to
do what they want on that device
but that their data is
also on that device as well,
that if they don't have the
data they need when they reach
for their tablet or their
laptop synced across all their
devices, it's increasingly
being viewed as a bug,
as a lack of feature.
So one of the things we can
deliver to you in Drive as
part of a platform
is that ability.
But there are lots of platforms
that can do that
sort of syncing functionality.
So what I want to talk about
this morning is why I think
Drive is the right one and some
of the unique values that
Drive brings to the table as a
platform to help you acquire
users but also deliver the
features that users expect, in
terms of data synchronization.
So Drive is a platform that does
sync all these things.
And this was the original
marketing position end of
Drive was all your stuff synced
in the cloud, safe
wherever you want it.
Why it's growing so rapidly and
what makes it unique and
what our users are really coming
to like and enjoy about
the product is that we provide
you not only with standard
syncing and storage but
also a very rich
experience in the cloud.
You don't have to download your
files to a device to do
something with them.
And there's a lot of different
ways we do this.
One of the ways is Preview.
You don't have to download
your file and have local
software in order to view
most file types.
Drive offers out-of-the-box on
the web previews for over 4 of
the most common file types
that users store.
You can also comment
on anything.
You can comment on things in
Docs, Slides, and Sheets, the
applications native to Drive.
Or you can comment on things
like images or Word docs or
Excel spreadsheets or
PDFs or anything.
So you can collaborate
with other users
around any type of file.
We also have some really
interesting search
capabilities.
Whenever you upload anything
into Drive, especially things
like images or PDFs, we will OCR
them and extract text that
makes it searchable.
But we also run that
image through the
Google Goggles' backend.
Which means if you have, say, a
picture of Mount Everest, it
will recognize that when
you search for Everest.
Some really, really cool stuff
that's unique to Drive.
You can share anything
with other users.
You can share things that you
can edit with an app.
You can share images.
You can share any file type in
Drive with other users and
work with those users
on things.
And then the thing I want to
focus on this morning that
makes it a unique experience
in the cloud are apps.
Now from the very beginning,
Drive has been about apps.
Before Drive was Drive,
it was a suite of
products called Docs.
These were collaborative
web-based applications that
let people work together
in the cloud.
So Drive, over time,
increasingly became the fabric
that tied these apps together.
And then it was rebranded Drive
last year and launch.
And these apps are still
the core part of
what makes Drive special.
So when we sat back and looked
at that, we decided it made a
whole lot of sense to not
limited users to just those
apps but open up the platform
for anybody to build apps like
those on top of Drive
as a platform.
And that's what I want
to talk about.
You can integrate with Drive
in a lot of different ways.
You can have, say, an Android
app and use Drive as a
harddrive in the cloud.
But one of the most unique and
I think interesting ways you
can integrate with Drive is you
can take your web app and
make it deeply integrated in
the Drive UI, and it will
appear just like the native
Drive apps, like Docs and
Slides and Sheets.
And it turns out that users
love this feature.
The apps that we've launched,
we're up to over 150 of these
kinds of deeply integrated
apps.
And users are using them and
installing them like crazy.
The weekly install growth
rate is growing 8%
on average per week.
Users are really, really
happy with it.
So Drive is a platform.
Joseph Walla, the CEO of
HelloFax, recently wrote a
very interesting article for
all things D, talking about
the value of Drive as a platform
in terms of cheaply
delivering users.
And it was a really interesting
article, and I
want to focus on this quote.
"350,000 installs worth of
Google integrations.
Didn't spend the single cent
to acquire them." And that
speaks to the value of Drive as
a platform and its ability
to deliver users to your
app, as app developers.
So it can deliver the users.
But what's even more interesting
than the fact that
you can gain users by
integrating with this as a
platform is the type of
user you can gain.
And what I want to focus on is
the quality and the unique
characteristics of
these users.
So we talk to our
partners a lot.
And we asked them, what kinds
of usage patterns are you
seeing for your users that you
acquire through Drive, versus
users that you might have
acquired through your
traditional user acquisition
channels?
I have a few case studies
I want to share.
The first one is SlideRocket.
So they compared their Drive
users to their non-Drive users
and saw some very interesting
patterns that we'll see
repeated throughout
the case studies.
The Drive users were three
times as active.
And they were over three and
a half times more likely to
create a presentation.
And then something that will
be interesting when we talk
about acquisition channels in
a minute, 26% of the users
they acquired came through one
SlideRocket user through Drive
sharing a presentation with
another Drive user.
The next one is Lucidchart.
Lucidchart has been
very successful
on the Drive platform.
And they have very similar
patterns to their numbers.
And this speaks to an element
I think is also even maybe
even more important than
engagement, and that's the
ability to monetize
your conversion.
The users that Lucidchart chart
acquires from Drive,
versus the ones they acquire
through traditional channels,
convert 40% more often.
They create three times
as many documents.
When used within the enterprise,
the teams are 50%
larger, and they spend four
times as much time in the app,
which is a really remarkable
set of characteristics.
So the users they acquire
through Drive tend to be much
more monetizable and
much more engaged.
These are very valuable users
they're acquiring.
And the last one is HelloFax.
And we talked about HelloFax
a second ago.
And you see something
similar is there.
Drive users create over a
quarter more faxes than
non-Drive users.
And they send twice as many
documents out for signature.
So these users that they're
acquiring through these
channels, very valuable, very
engaged, high-quality users.
So what do we do in Drive as
a platform to deliver these
users to your app?
And then Steve will talk about
how you can best take
advantage of these acquisition
channels.
I just want to walk through a
handful them and just give you
a sense for the things we do to
deliver these high-quality
engaged users.
This is something we launched
in Q1 of this year.
And we totally re-architected
the Drive Create menu.
In the past, if you have any
experience with this as a
platform, if you were a
third-party app, you were
difficult to discover.
You were buried under
a submenu.
We were highlighting our
first-party apps.
Now you can see the way
it looks today.
You have the first-party apps
there in the left column.
But as users install
more apps, these
are given equal billing.
Very discoverable, very easy to
find after if you install
it, and it really centers the
message that we're trying to
convey that this
is a platform.
We really want users to engage
with your apps, with
third-party apps, and the new
Create menu reflects that.
Another really interesting
aspect of this feature, you'll
notice down at the bottom the
Connect More Apps button.
In the past, surfacing the store
where you could find
Drive apps was very difficult.
But now it's almost impossible
to miss.
And that drives more and more
users to the listing.
In fact, when we compared the
install rate for the month
prior to this feature launch to
the month after, we found
that users were installing these
apps at a 68% increased
rate after the feature
launched.
Another way we're helping you
succeed on our platform is if
you have any experience, if
you've use the Drive platform
as a Drive app before, you
remember we had an install
flow that wasn't entirely
optimal.
It was based on the
Chrome Web Store.
So when a user installed
the app, you got
a Chrome app installed.
And then you also had the app
installed into Drive.
And that was a bit confusing
to users.
Well, we fixed all that.
Now when you click that giant
Connect More Apps button in
the Create menu, you
get this, an
in-context Drive app widget.
It doesn't force the user to go
off to a separately-branded
Chrome Web Store.
It's an in-Drive installation
process.
And the flow is really
smooth now.
So I can simply connect
an app.
And you can see you get this
nice dialogue here.
Floorplanner was connected.
And then it's going to promo
the user back to the Create
menu so that they can find
how to launch the app.
So we're really hoping to
simplify that process so users
can install apps easily and then
discover how to use them
in the app more easily.
I think this may be the
most important one.
And that's the things we do
around the sharing flow.
In this example, in
uses Lucidchart.
So imagine I create a Lucidchart
diagram, and then I
want to share it with
some colleagues
that I'm working with.
They don't have the
app installed.
They may never even have
heard of Lucidchart.
But when I share it to them,
they'll see this here in this
little highlighted
box on the left.
That's the "Shared
With Me" view.
And the Lucidchart item
shows up there.
Now as a recipient of that,
I may not even know what
Lucidchart.
Is.
I don't know how to go find
it and install it.
But fortunately, we take
care of that for you.
As soon as you click on that
item, it will pop up this
Lucidchart install dialog.
All the user has to do is like,
yeah, that sounds great.
Connect and done.
You can open that diagram that
someone shared with you and
begin editing it right away.
So that's a great user
acquisition channel.
Because people in Drive
love to share
things with other users.
And as they start to share,
installs of your app can
spread with those sharing
networks, which is an
incredibly valuable feature.
The last one is some things
we're doing with
the new Drive Previewer.
If you use Drive, you might have
noticed that we launched
a new in-context Preview
with the black
lightbox-style viewer.
And this allows you to preview
tons of different file types
right there in the
context of Drive.
There's a feature that's coming
where you can click
Connect More Apps down
there on the bottom,
off the Open menu.
And depending on what you're
looking at, if you're looking
at an image--
In this particular example, the
user is looking at some
sort of audio file.
When they click it, it's going
to show you the apps
specifically scoped to be able
to do something with
that type of file.
So if a user's looking at a
type of file and it like,
there's not much I can do with
this, they can easily go look
for apps that can do something
more with it.
And that's where your app can
really step in and provide a
much better experience for
that type of file.
So that's how we're helping
deliver more
users to your app.
And now Steve's going to come
talk about different ways you
can take advantage of
Drive as a platform.
STEVEN BAZYL: Thanks, Josh.
As Josh showed, there's a lot
of opportunity for apps that
integrate with Drive.
And I want to talk to you
about how to take
advantage of that.
I'm not going to do a detailed
walk through how to
build a Drive app.
Honestly, it's really not that
hard and between the
documentation on
developers.google.com, the
sample apps that we have on
GitHub, I'm pretty sure
everyone in this room is going
to be able to figure it out
without too much difficulty.
That said, I do want to talk
about the general process for
building an app, because there's
a few things that you
do along the way that have a
significant impact on how
users perceive your app.
And if done right, your chances
of being noticed by
users and adopted, as you saw
with vendors like HelloFax, is
dramatically better.
If you don't do these things
well, the chances of your app
being discovered by users
is close to nil.
So in terms of building a Drive
app, the process is
pretty easy.
And for those who have used
Google APIs before, you've
probably been to the Google
APIs console.
It's a really easy tool for
where you create your project.
This is where you just tell us
about your app, tell us how
it's connecting, which
APIs it's using.
And it's also where you can
figure how your application
integrates with the Drive UI.
It's pretty easy to
create a project.
And once you do that, one of the
first things they're going
to do is configure OAuth.
Hopefully everybody here
is familiar with OAuth.
It's just a protocol for you
to securely access our APIs
and the users' data.
And to create an OAuth client
ID, you just need to provide a
few bits of information.
It's basically some branding
information to identify your
application, the name, icons,
what type of application it
is-- in this case, we're talking
about web apps--
and where it's hosted.
Pretty easy stuff.
And then once that's done, you
get a client ID and a secret
that's generated for you, and
use that in your code.
The other thing that comes into
OAuth is the level of
access that your application
needs.
And the reason why I want to
bring up this is all of this
information is presented
to users at a
really critical time.
It's when they're being asked to
make a judgment call about
whether or not they trust your
app to access their data.
And you usually see a
screen like this.
So in this case, this
is Lucidchart.
They actually did everything
right here.
They asked for a very, very
small amount of access, just
the files that the user created
or they chose open.
They have really nice branding
information.
There's really not that much
reason to think that this app
is untrustworthy.
You'd be surprised with the
number of apps that I've seen
that have things like "test"
or "staging" in their name,
because the developers never
went back and actually updated
this information, or they
have a broken icon.
But more significantly is
the level of access.
And that can actually have a
dramatic impact on whether or
not users are going to click
Allow Access or No Thanks.
Drive offer a pretty broad range
of scopes for the level
of access you have to Drive.
You can ask for very restrictive
access, just
individual files that the user
chooses to share with you,
various levels of read-only
access to metadata to content.
And then at the opposite end,
full access to the user's
Drive, where you can do pretty
much anything you want.
If you ask for a lot of access,
you really should have
a good reason to do it.
And it should be clear from what
your app does why you're
asking for that level
of detail.
Users really do pay
attention to this.
And we've seen apps that have
requested just far, far, far
too many permissions for what
the app was really designed to
do and have seen the
accept rates for
these installs to drop.
So once you've done OAuth,
there's one other thing you
have to do, which is just turn
on access to Drive API.
And then once you've done
this, you've actually
completed basically the
first couple steps of
our Quickstart examples.
And if you haven't used the
Drive API before, I would
encourage you to actually go and
go to the documentation.
And right at the top of the page
are a set of Quickstarts.
And they're in different
languages, different
server-side languages, some
mobile ones as well, and they
take about five minutes
to get up and started.
And what you saw of just
creating that OAuth client is
probably three or four minutes
of that exercise.
It's really easy.
The nice things with these
Quickstarts is they give you a
platform where you can
experiment with the API.
Because you're up and running
with a working application in
just a few minutes, and then
you start learning the API,
modifying that code, and getting
a better feel for how
it works in the language
of your choice.
So let's fast forward and say
that we've done this.
We've played with
the Quickstart.
We've learned how do reading
and writing of files, and
everything's good.
And now we're ready to actually
integrate our app in
the UI so that we can do all of
the things that Josh showed
you, where I can create a file,
I can open things and
launch my application.
When you enable the Drive SDK
in the console, you get an
additional page in
the console.
And there's really two sets of
information that you need to
provide here.
One is largely cosmetic.
It's a lot of information
about your app name,
description, and icons.
And these are things that
affect how your app is
presented to the user
within Drive.
When you're developing, you
don't have to pay too much
attention to these.
But when it comes to going into
production, make sure
that these are high-quality
images, that the description
of your application is short
and it's concise, it's
reflective of what
your app does.
Because these are some of the
things that are show to users
in those different scenarios
that Josh showed you.
The other bit of information
that you need to provide is
information about how your app
connects with Google Drive.
And this is more the
functional section.
And there's two things, really,
the URL for your
application.
When somebody clicks Open
or the click Create,
where do they go?
The other thing that's really
important is the types of
files that your application
can work with.
And the reason I want to point
is it can actually have a
dramatic impact on the
user experience.
There are two sets of files
here that we have.
We have what we call default
types, and we have what we
call secondary types.
And for either one, you can do
MIME types or file extensions.
And we take the union.
So it works they way
you would expect.
But the difference between
default and secondary is
important to understand.
If you put a file type in the
default section, that means
every time a user clicks on a
file of that type your app is
going to be the default
action.
If it's in the secondary type,
it means that your app can
open that file but the user
would have to do it a
right-click or a contextual
open.
The reason this is important is
we see far too many apps be
overzealous about claiming file
types and making their
app the default for them, things
that really aren't
appropriate for that
application.
And to give you an example of
the extreme of where this
would be bad is suppose I built
an online printing or
fax application.
If I put 20 different document
types as the default, that
would just annoy the
user to no end.
And the consequence is either
that user is going to have to
go into the Settings, and
they're going to have to
change the configuration to
make my app no longer the
default, or worse, and probably
more likely, is
they're just going to uninstall
my app because it's
just not behaving correctly.
So you really want to be
thoughtful here about which
files you want your app to be
the default for and which ones
you just want to be capable of
opening, and probably err on
the conservative side.
If you become the default, you
can significantly change the
behavior of how Drive
works for that user.
And if not done right, it can
be a really negative change
for those users.
And here you can see this
is just the view.
If you're a secondary type, you
appear in the Open With.
So you can still open files,
just one click removed in
order to protect the
user experience.
So let's fast forward
a little bit more.
We've written some code.
We handled these URLs.
And we configured everything
in the SDK settings.
We need to install our app.
And there's two ways
you can do this.
We have one through the Install
mechanism that Josh
showed with embedded Chrome
Web Store widget.
A simpler way-- and this
is a great way
to do it for testing--
is to OAuth.
And so you can just authorize
your application, include one
additional scope called the
drive.install.scope, and your
app will be enabled, and you get
all those cool features.
And the nice thing is this
actually works really well in
production too.
So when you combine it with
something like the Google+
Sign In button, you can actually
have a really amazing
experience where I can go to an
application, I can sign in,
and I get things like the
Drive app installation.
But I also get things like
over-the-air installation if a
multi-platform app.
And it's just with one click.
So it's a really nice
user experience.
And it's something that, if you
have a lot of users coming
to your site directly, they
can benefit from the
integration with Drive without
having to go through
additional steps in order to
go to Drive and install the
app separately.
So you can actually just do
this all in one gesture.
The other way, though,
as I mentioned, is
a Chrome Web Store.
And Josh showed you what
that widget looks like.
And we're doing an embedded
view of Chrome
Web Store for Drive.
But the way that you configure
that application and the way
that you provide those assets
is still through
the Chrome Web Store.
And a lot of the rules for the
Chrome Web Store, in terms of
how you construct your app,
what you need to provide,
still apply for the
Drive case.
A couple things I want
to point out.
Again, the process for doing
this is not difficult.
And you can go to the
documentation and go to the
Chrome Web Store console, and
you'll figure it out.
But I do want to point out some
of the things that users
see so you'll understand, the
information that you're
providing, how that reflects in
Drive and how we show apps.
Of course, we have the different
tile images and the
short description of
your application.
And these are the first things
users are going to see when
they're trying to discover
applications.
It's a little known fact about
these images when you create
an entry in the Chrome Web
Store, and that's that they're
all manually reviewed.
There's actually strict
guidelines about what these
images can contain in order
for them to be approved.
You don't want these images
to be rejected.
If you do, the chances of your
app being discovered by a user
are effectively zero.
You will appear below every
other app that has done the
process correctly.
And worse, you will get these
little teeny tiny tiles that
really just show your icon and
your application name.
As a user, I have very little
incentive to go and click on
any one of those apps.
Those are simply
not appealing.
And knowing that those
developers didn't go through
the proper steps in order to
make their app interesting to
me throws a lot of doubt into
my mind whether or not that
app is really worth using.
So some of the things that can
get those images rejected are
things like too much text, too
little text-- if the font
sizes are too small
and unreadable--
the images are blurry,
if they're too busy.
Generally, you can go to
the Chrome Web Store
documentation, and there's a
list of six or seven different
criteria for what makes
a good image.
And there's some examples of
some bad images and some good
images that you can use
as a reference.
These are not difficult
things.
It probably takes you an hour
or two to have a really nice
image crafted up for you.
But it works.
And the difference between going
through this correctly
and skimping on this is
dramatic, in terms of how
users perceive your app.
Of course, you still have to
get the Detail page right,
providing a nice icon, quality
screenshots, a detailed
description.
And more importantly, in the
description of your app,
certainly explain what it does,
but also explain why the
integration with Driver
is useful for users.
We've seen a lot of applications
that just talk
about their application, but
users just don't know why the
integration with Drive
is any better.
And these are apps that are
providing tremendous value.
But they just do such a poor
job at explaining it.
Again, take the time
to craft this.
This is just a few minutes of
work but, again, has such a
huge impact on how users are
perceiving your app and
whether or not they're likely
to connect it to Drive.
So far, a lot of this has been
focused on first impressions.
This is all surface stuff.
And at the end of the day,
that's great for getting
people to try your app.
But really you want people to
love your app and use it and
be engaged.
And one of the things
with platforms--
this is true for Drive--
it's a meritocracy.
We don't pick winners.
We don't pick favorites.
We rely on the users to
tell us which apps
are the best apps.
And they do that by providing
ratings and reviews for the
apps that they try.
So it's up to you, as
developers, to build
applications that users
are going to love.
And there's a few things in the
Drive API that you can use
to make sure that your
integration with Drive is as
good as it can be.
And I'm going to go through
a couple of those--
there are going to be two that
are very simple things that
you can do--
and then talk about some of
the deeper features in the
Drive API that you can use to
provide a really amazing
experience.
So that's what you
want to get to.
You want to get to five stars.
So the first is something
Josh talked about.
The Drive UI has been
evolving towards
having very rich previews.
We have a grid view for when
people are browsing files
along with this lightbox-style
way of quickly previewing and
navigating through
your content.
We do a great job at providing
previews for a lot of
different formats.
Third-party content,
though, is a little
bit difficult sometimes.
And this is what users see if we
don't know how to make that
content previewable.
When you're developing your app,
take a look at how your
content that your app creates
appears in this view.
And if we're not being able to
provide a preview for you,
there's actually something
really simple that you can do
to fix this.
It's a little-known feature
in the Drive API.
We actually allow
you to provide
thumbnails for your images.
And I would actually say the
term thumbnails is probably
inappropriate, because
these images can
actually be very large.
It can be up to two megabytes.
And we encourage you to provide
these images in as
large as a format as you can
within that two megabyte limit
so that when somebody views a
file and they're going through
and doing a grid view or they're
in the lightbox, they
will see a preview of your
content that's appropriate for
your application and for
that content type.
It's really easy, just a base64
encoded P&G image.
It's part of the metadata.
So if you can generate a
preview, check it out.
Make sure your content
looks correct.
If it doesn't, provide us an
image, and then we'll show
that to a user in these
different views.
It's a really easy thing to do,
makes the integration with
Drive a lot more seamless.
Similarly, search is really
important for Drive.
Search your Drive pretty
much on a daily basis.
We do a really good job on all
sorts of different content.
Even with images,
we can do image
recognition of landmarks.
We can do OCR, recognize text.
And of course, different
content, document formats are
all really well indexed.
But again, we have the
same problem with
some third-party types.
We just simply don't know how
to index that content.
So when you're developing, again
try searching for the
content that you create, and
make sure it's discoverable.
If it is, great.
You don't have to do anything.
If it's not, a very simple
thing you can do is just
provide us alternate
text to index.
And when you upload your files
or when you update them, you
can just provide us a block of
text, fairly large even, up to
about 128k, and we will index
that as if that were the
content of the file.
If your file happens to be text
format and you just want
us to index it as-is, there's
a query parameter.
You can just say, treat this
content as indexable.
We'll ignore the type of file
and just try to index it as
best we can.
So again, it's a really
easy thing to do.
It's just a little
quick checkmark.
Try searching for
your content.
If it doesn't work the way you
expect, you can fix it.
So two really easy things that
can make the user experience
for integrated apps much
more seamless.
So there's a couple more things
I want to talk about.
These are a little bit deeper
usage of the API, but I think
they're really important.
And mostly they come around the
concept of collaboration.
Josh talked a little bit about
sharing, and sharing is very
popular in Drive.
And it's a great way for people
to learn about your app
and discover it.
But more important than sharing
is, once you share it,
being able to work together.
And there's two features
of the API that I
want to talk about.
And these are ways that we can
help you build applications
that have amazing sharing and
collaborative experiences.
The first is the
real time API.
This is something we launched
about two months ago.
It is a super fun API.
I have been having a blast just
building samples for this.
It is just crazy cool what you
can do with very little code.
There's a bunch of sample apps
up on GitHub, a couple apps in
the sandbox.
Actually, yesterday
we had Ganter.
Today, I believe we have
draw.io, which is a
diagramming app.
And then tomorrow is Neutron
Drive, which is an IDE.
And all three of these are using
the API to provide the
same type of collaborative
experience that we provide
within Docs, but they're doing
it within their own app.
And for those who are interested
in this API,
there's actually a really great
talk later today from
Brian and Charles, two
engineers that
have worked on this.
And they do a fantastic job
going into how the API works,
some of the complexities and
the problem that they're
trying to solve, and why having
a really beautiful,
simple API for doing this
is so valuable.
So definitely check it out.
But it's a great way to go
from just simply sharing
content to making that content
interactive and collaborative.
The other way you can do this
is using the Comments API.
Josh mentioned commenting as a
feature of our own editors.
It's also part of
the Drive API.
You can actually add commenting
capabilities to any
application and any file
stored in Drive.
And it's really easy to do.
You do have to provide the UI
for it, but you do get all the
same features.
You get the ability to have
the state for threads, at
mentions, email notifications.
All the things that go into the
document commenting that
you see in Drive and Docs today,
again, can be used in
your application.
So these are just two examples
of things that you can do to
make your application an amazing
experience for people
who use Drive.
There are some other things in
Drive as a platform that are
little bit lower-level, more
technical things that are
coming out or have launched
recently, things like private
application data, metadata for
files, which is really awesome
for things like workflow
applications.
And we've got things like Push
notifications launching in the
next few weeks.
The point of this, though, is
Drive really is a platform
that you can build amazing
applications with, that have
just incredible experiences
where you can annotate docs,
you can have amazing
collaborative experiences.
In fact, the last collaborative
app I built, I
didn't even have a server for.
The content is hosted
on GitHub, so I'm
using GitHub Pages.
And it's a fully persistent,
collaborative, real time
application that lets people
work on to-do lists, and it's
like 100 lines of JavaScript,
a little bit more than that,
but it's really not that much.
But it's just hosted
on GitHub Pages.
And just that idea that I can
build something that is along
the lines of Google Docs or
presentations or Slides and
not have to worry about servers
or anything is kind of
an amazing concept.
So one thing, before
we go to questions.
I think what we've seen today
from applications that are
integrated with Drive is really
just version one.
There are some great apps
that people have built.
I love some of these.
I love HelloFax.
I love Lucidchart.
These are apps that I have
installed on my own personal
account, and they're great.
But with things like the real
time API and some of these
deeper features, there's still
a huge opportunity for
applications to build unique,
amazing experiences for people
who use Google Drive and fully
exploit the platform and build
apps that are as good, or if not
better than any of the ON
apps that we've built
ourselves.
And I think there's a ton of
potential for this and things,
everything from education--
especially with what you've
seen with WebGL and "The
Hobbit" at the keynote, to
build, why can't I have 3D
collaborative modeling or Cat
editing, and how that can
transform different industries
that are so used to being able
to work in these legacy
applications, just one user at
a time, sharing files around,
shipping them via FTP.
There's a huge opportunity.
And the challenge for you is to
go and build something that
is the next Google Docs,
or if not bigger.
And Josh?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
STEVEN BAZYL: I think we're
ready for questions.
JOSH HUDGINS: Questions.
We have two mics here
in the center.
So if you do have questions,
please go to the mics.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Steven.
A quick question around
MIME types.
We'd love to be able to do
something very similar to
folders, to basically have typed
folders, and this is a
container of our type, which
holds things that we hold,
additional metadata,
et cetera.
Is that something you
can comment on?
STEVEN BAZYL: I would love
to chat more about
what you want to do.
Certainly, you can
do things with
folders and create folders.
We actually even have Open
With on folders now.
So you can open them with
your application.
But in terms of being able to
have different types, it's not
something that we've
really discussed.
But I would love to hear more
about what the particular use
case is, what you're
trying to do.
And maybe there's ways to
do it with what we have.
And if there isn't, it's
definitely something
we could look at.
But I would have to really
understand more about what the
use case is.
JOSH HUDGINS: Let's talk
more after about that.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned earlier
that the level of
permission you ask for
have an impact on
the conversion rates.
Do you have some harder numbers
so that we can--
It's difficult to A/B test that
kind of thing and change
it after the fact and stuff.
So being able to make a more
informed choice on the
permissions that we ask for
and being able to actually
inform trade that off would
be really helpful.
STEVEN BAZYL: I don't
have them with me.
I actually did chat with one of
the engineers on the Auth
team a couple days ago about
this, because I actually did
want to find those
numbers myself.
And I also want to get some
metrics on things like
branding and so on, what the
actual quantitative impact is.
So I am, actually, trying
to get those numbers.
As soon as I get them, I'll
try to share them on the
community, assuming
I can share them.
But yeah, I do want to actually
get that information
out as soon as I can.
I just don't have it
with me today.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I noticed recently
in the Chrome Store there's
advertisements now.
How do you do that?
STEVEN BAZYL: What was that?
AUDIENCE: I've noticed that
there's advertisements in the
Chrome Store.
It'll have the apps on the
front page, and it'll say
advertisements.
How do you do that?
How do you get into that?
STEVEN BAZYL: That
I don't know.
Josh, do you happen to
know about that?
JOSH HUDGINS: I don't
know the precise--
I know kind of high-level about
how that program works,
but I can't tell you the
exact URL to go to.
But let me find that out and
then follow up with you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So there's a page that you can
go to to sign up for it?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
It's like a type of ad product
that you can--
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is on the
permission side.
So if we are building an app,
can we actually build some
sort of UI within the sharing
window, like an expiration of
sharing after something or even
with a password protect
or something like that.
STEVEN BAZYL: Not directly
with Drive.
I've seen people build other
tools around Drive using the
API to do things like that and
provide some automation.
Actually, we had a hackathon
about three
or four months ago.
And one of the hackathon
participants built an app like
that where they would do things
like tying down sharing
and so on and additional
password protection on links.
So you can do it
with the APIs.
It's just not a feature
of Drive.
AUDIENCE: The APIs
are irrelevant.
It's just that we're to do it
outside the Drive within
another third-party app.
STEVEN BAZYL: It's not
a feature of Drive.
But again, you could build it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEVEN BAZYL: Just
do you have to?
That's the question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for doing this.
I'm Noble.
I work with enterprises
traditionally.
And we've got the Google Apps
Store or that Marketplace and
we also have the Chrome
Marketplace.
Is there any plans to sort of
bring that to parity, to just
simplify stuff for some
of us developers.
JOSH HUDGINS: That's
a great question.
One of the issues we're trying
to address now is if you look
at how the Chrome Web Store
widget that we've embedded in
Drive works today is it doesn't
do a great job of
addressing a lot of the use
cases that the Apps
Marketplace does.
And so one of the things we're
working at really closely is
how we can bring the feature
sets of those different
marketplaces together to make
sure that if you do have a
Drive app that you want that
enterprises can use it and
provision it and administer it
within an enterprise and do
domain licensing and
provisioning and
that sort of thing.
So yeah.
I think you'll see some things
there over time.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
And one thing to mention too is
a lot of the folks from the
enterprise side, particularly
some of the PMs working on the
Apps Marketplace, are going to
be over at the Office Hours
this afternoon.
The person you'd most likely
want to talk to for where the
Apps Marketplace is going
is Apoorv Saxena.
Apoorv.
He should be over there, I
think, around probably between
about 1:30 and 3:00.
I'll probably be over there.
If he's around, come by.
I'll get you introduced, and you
can get a little bit more
detail about where the
Marketplace is going
and with all that.
AUDIENCE: It's 1:45.
STEVEN BAZYL: What's that?
1:45?
OK.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I want to know the attitude
for Google Docs
intercollection with Microsoft
Office's 365 and/or some other
Cloud Office applications,
such as [INAUDIBLE]
and IBM Docs.
And in your mind, how many
benefits can Google Docs get
from the intercollection?
Thank you.
JOSH HUDGINS: The question
is about
integrating Docs with 365?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOSH HUDGINS: What specifically
are you curious about?
AUDIENCE: I mentioned the Cloud
Office intercollection.
I submitted an IETF internet
draft for this topic.
JOSH HUDGINS: Let's
talk after.
And we can dig into it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOSH HUDGINS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned the importance of
requesting only the scope
that you need for your
application.
Are there any plans to allow us
to annotate why we need a
certain scope?
Because sometimes you do need
the scope, but it might not be
intuitively obvious to the user
and may reject you out of
hand because they think, oh,
why do they need that?, and
throw out the app.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
I don't know of any hard
plans for that.
I know there's a lot of
discussion going on around
there's constantly ways to
improve that and various ideas
that I've heard internally But
I can't really give you any
definitive answer.
We actually had done that
before with the Apps
Marketplace.
There were questions
earlier about that.
And that's actually a feature
that's in the Apps Marketplace
is annotated scopes that are
displayed to administrators.
And you get a one
to two sentence
description as to why.
So we do it in some context.
Just in terms of the
consumer-level auth screens
and approvals, that feature
has just never
been part of it.
JOSH HUDGINS: I think one thing
we can do to make that
easier is make it where there's
fewer situations where
you have to unintuitively
request a scope that users
don't understand, like in order
to implement a certain
feature We should make,
for instance, our more
fine-grained scopes work across
all the features in a
way that users expect.
So if you have to request
broader access for something,
they understand why without
really having to dig into it.
And I think if I were going to
tackle that problem, that's
the way I'd like to do it.
Because there's a few things--
I probably can identify some
of the scenarios you've run
into where you have to request
a wider scope than you would
otherwise need just
to implement a
certain type of feature.
And that's a lot of times
because of a shortcoming of
the implementation of the
finer-grain scopes.
So over time, if we can fix to
where users, oh, it makes
perfect sense that you would
request the scopes you're
requesting, given what you're
trying to do as an app.
I think that's probably
the high-level
direction we would go there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: This is kind of an
implementation detail.
But when a user shares a file
within the Drive interface,
does your app get some kind of
notification so that behind
the scenes our servers can
update the permissions so that
when that shared user opens up
the file we can make sure that
they still have permission
and authentication?
STEVEN BAZYL: There is a change
feed that you can use
to watch for changes
to a user's Drive.
So you can get some level
of notification.
I would question more the
attempt to synchronize
permissions, because that is
error-prone and can actually
create security holes, if
not done correctly.
For a Drive app, you really
have to pick one as
the source of truth.
And the recommendation is, if
you are a Drive app and you
are relying on sharing, that
you check the Drive ACLs.
And you would do that just when
somebody opens the file.
If they can read it in Drive,
that implicitly means they
should be able to read it
in your application.
There may be certain cases where
you do need to keep that
in sync, in which case you
would just use the change
collection to watch for changes
to that user's corpus.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you need to watch the change,
essentially, on the
receiving end?
STEVEN BAZYL: Right.
Exactly.
And then you would know, oh, a
new file is available to you.
And then you can reconcile
that on your side.
But the easier thing
is just to not
synchronize ACLs like that.
AUDIENCE: And just leverage
the Drive's ACLs.
OK.
Great.
Thanks.
JOSH HUDGINS: The more generic
problem is we will be coming
out with the Push notifications
system here.
And you can access it now if
you're in the Early Access
Program too, which will
solve some of
those types of problems.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My question is about the new
recent collaboration of
Chatting and Documents.
Will there be an API expanded
for our apps on that, so we
can do the collaborating
chat in our own apps?
JOSH HUDGINS: Using
real time API?
AUDIENCE: Can you do that
using real time?
JOSH HUDGINS: We have partners
that have implemented Chat
using real time API.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
JOSH HUDGINS: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the service.
I think it's fantastic.
Currently, I think you can only
sell per user and not by
a company or domain.
Has there been any thought
of improving that?
JOSH HUDGINS: Yeah.
And this is very much along
the lines of the earlier
comments around the Apps
Marketplace versus the
ecosystem that uses the Chrome
Web Store embeddable widgit.
It's something we're thinking
about quite a bit and focusing
on right now.
So stay tuned.
AUDIENCE: Is there a timetable,
like within a year?
JOSH HUDGINS: Nothing I probably
want to share with
this broad of an audience.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
JOSH HUDGINS: So something we're
thinking about for sure.
STEVEN BAZYL: All right.
If there's no more questions,
we'll be up at the Office
Hours probably for the next
half hour, in case anyone
wants to stop by later.
But other than that, thank
you all for coming.
JOSH HUDGINS: Thanks, guys.